Der italienische rocksängerin gianna vero wird auch, als kopf ab arzt rebell und doktor frankenstein
Bezeichnet fest steht er hat einen
unvorstellbaren plan denn er wird tatsächlich der erste sein der einen menschlichen kopf auf den körper eines anderen
transportiert damit will cannavaro
menschliches leben verlängern cyborgs erschaffen und lange weltraummissionen enorm vereinfachen seine kritiker bezeichnen den plan als
makaber und
Unethisch doch klar ist auch es wäre eine unfassbare
Revolution, im medizinischen bereich wie sein blutiger plan konkret aussieht welche hürden er dafür noch
Zu nehmen hat und ob es wirklich zu diesem riesigen szenario kommen wird jetzt in klicks um science-fiction herzlich willkommen
An dieser stelle einen riesen dank an meine whatsapp
Community hier wurde das thema vorgeschlagen und hier ist es auch schon wie ihr dabei sein könnt also bei der community erfahrt ihr am ende
des videos er sorgt immer wieder für schlagzeilen denn sergio cannavaro
Ist hartnäckig und lässt sich auch von den zahlreichen
kritikern und kritikerinnen nicht beirren sein plan steht fest schon seit jahren will er der erste sein der eine kopf
Transplantation durchführt bei einem lebenden menschen er beruft sich dabei auf seine aufgabe als mediziner menschen zu helfen beispielsweise
Patienten die gelähmt sind und im rollstuhl
Sitzen doch das spielt wohl nur eine untergeordnete rolle
Kam vero geht es hauptsächlich um eine technologie die leben verlängert menschen jünger macht denn ein alter kopf
könnte seiner meinung nach quasi durch einen jungen körper regeneriert werden und der
italienischen neurochirurg denkt noch weiter
stichwort cyborgs zum beispiel konkret meinte damit einen menschlichen kopf auf einem maschinellen körper
war gänsehaut oder und seine vision betreffen weitere bereiche er denkt auch an die raumfahrt und sieht erfolgreiche kopf
transplantation als schlüssel
Um gegen die über population der erde durch die menschen anzukommen in einem interview mit der österreichischen zeitung kurier
Hat cannavaro einmal gesagt dass wir in der zukunft vor gezwungen sein werden andere planeten wie den mars zu
Besiedeln und auf der langen reise dorthin wäre ein kopf transplantation eine gute möglichkeit
Das leben der menschen zu verlängern seine überzeugung ist es auch dass man dafür auch, mal grenzen
überschreiten soll er vergleicht seine kritiker mit den zweifeln zahlreicher medizinerinnen und mediziner bevor die erste herztransplantation
weltweit stattgefunden hat cannavaro sieht sich selbst in der tradition
solcher medizin pioniere sein projekt heißt helfen
2013 hat er das erste mal der öffentlichkeit vorgestellt und häfen steht für head an astro moses venture
Von head für kopf affe an astro moses also eine verbindung von anatomische strukturen und wenn für venture
wagners und sein plan sei bereits weitgehend
fortgeschritten drei stufen seien dafür notwendig die erste ist seiner ansicht nach bereits sehr erfolgreich verlaufen bei der komplizierten operation wurde der kopf einer frischen
männerleiche auf den körper einer anderen gesetz beide körper waren zu forschungszwecken
freigegeben die op dauerte 18 stunden überhaupt cannavaro verließ sie nach plan fest steht jedoch auch dass man hier nicht
überprüfen konnte ob die blutversorgung
Des gehirns die zeit über gewährleistet war und das ist ein sehr entscheidender punkt
Genau dieser aspekt soll jetzt in der zweiten stufe geklärt werden diese soll an zwei hirntoten spendern
durchgeführt werden deren herz aber noch schlägt
Diese aktion steht als nächstes auf ghana virus agenda doch auch hier gibt es wie gesagt noch einige dinge
zu klären und auch bei stufe 3 von den dreien dem großen finale sind noch fragen offen
Hauptsächlich im ethischen bereich denn bislang findet sich kein land der welt dass es zulässt dass cannavaro seine ideen in die praxis
umsetzt trotz dieser hürden steht der ablauf der finalen kopf
transplantation schon sehr konkret fest aber achtung das ist jetzt echt nichts für schwache nerven mehr als
100 spezialisten und spezialistin werden beteiligt sein den kopf eines körperlich schwer kranken menschen auf den körper eines hirntoten
Spenders zu setzen spender und empfänger werden zuvor heruntergekühlt auf etwa 12 grad um die ihren zellen in eine art
standby modus zu versetzen
denn hier brauchen sie weitaus weniger sauerstoff als gewöhnlich und können einige zeit ohne blutzirkulation
auskommen 12 chirurgen werden spender und fenger operieren beide werden dazu in einem
metallgestell sitzen dass sie fixiert ein wirklich großes bild wie eben schon gesagt ist vor allem die blutversorgung, des gehirns
entscheidung diese zu gewährleisten wird am tag vor der op einen, bypass an der halsschlagader des empfängers gelegt
Am großen tag selbst folgen dann die freilegung von muskeln sehnen
arterien und so weiter und zwar synchron bei spender und empfänger
körper dann wird der körper von kopf
getrennt und zwar zwischen dem fünften und dem sechsten halswirbel und dann bleibt nur sehr kurze zeit um die oberen teile der metall gestelle zu
Tauschen und den kopf des spenders mit dem körper des empfängers zu verbinden arterien
Luftröhre dann die speiseröhre und die wirbelsäule doch hier herrscht
Große skepsis denn viele experten teams erscheint es als
Unlösbare aufgabe das rückenmark wieder so zu verbinden dass es auch funktionsfähig ist denn dies würde ja auch die heilung wieder
querschnittsgelähmte patienten bedeuten kann avéro
Argumentiert jedoch dass es einen unterschied gäbe bei rückenmark das mit einem sauberen schnitt durchtrennt wurde sei es möglich die
Beschädigten nerven mit bestimmten stoffen zu versiegeln und dann auch wieder zu verbinden konkret hat er hier den wirkstoff träger namens
polyethylenglykol
Pg im kopf er beruft sich auf tierversuche in denen durchtrennt das rückenmark wieder erfolgreich verbunden werden konnte
andere experten und expertinnen aus dem medizinischen bereich sehen das äußerst kritisch und
hinterfragen das potenzial von p&g einige bezeichnen cannavaros ideen auch als menschen versuche die ethische standards unterlaufen
Der großteil der mediziner und medizinerin jedenfalls ich sich einig dass die wissenschaft zum heutigen zeitpunkt noch nicht so weit
sei ja und der
neurochirurg dagegen beruft sich auf zahlreiche tests ja doch die sagen bei weitem noch nicht aus oder genug
Aus um seine geplante kopf transplantation an lebenden menschen durchzuführen und tatsächlich wäre seinen eingriff nur dann erfolgreich und noch viel mehr
also eine medizinische revolution
Wenn der körper dem neuen gehirn gehorcht und sich bewegen kann obwohl die wirbelsäule durchtrennt war doch selbst wenn das tatsächlich
Klappen würde ist fraglich was das mit der psyche
Des patienten oder der patientin machen würden nur als beispiel der patient der die erste hand
Transplantation bekam ließ dass einige zeit später wieder rückgängig machen er konnte die neue hand nicht hat seine eigene an agenten viele
transplantierte berichten von
persönlichkeitsveränderungen und es gibt natürlich viele weitere ethische fragen kann man teile des körpers wie ein ersatzteillager behandeln und
Austauschen ist der körper nicht mehr als ein anhängsel des kopfes
dennoch tauchen immer wieder neue schlagzeilen auf die den termin für das große ereignis der ersten kopf transplantation ankündigen
Im jahr 2016 jesus das experiment werde ende 2017 stattfinden dann wurde es verschoben ende 2017 wurde es dann auf
2018 terminiert es soll an der haben medical
University in china stattfinden werden ja schon berichtet dass dort viel mehr möglich ist um den fortschritt, des landes
Eben deutlich nach vorne zu treiben doch auch das ist mittlerweile sehr unsicher denn einige chinesische behörden haben
zweifel angemeldet dass eine solche kopf transplantation bei menschen mit chinesischem, recht
vereinbar wäre zudem schlägt sich der italienische
neurochirurg neben den ganzen ethischen bedenken auch noch mit anderen fragen herum denn eine wichtige voraussetzung für seine pläne sind passende
kandidaten oder kandidatinnen
er selbst vergleicht das öfter mal mit der suche nach dem passenden astronauten für die mondlandung denn nicht nur
geschlecht hautfarbe und körpergröße müssen stimmen sondern auch der immun typ längerer zeit galt der russe waleri
Spiridonow als geeigneter kandidat für das experiment doch
Mittlerweile, sieht es so aus als könnte das projekt möglicherweise in china stattfinden das problem der kopf des russen würde vom körperbau und
Der hautfarbe nicht so der eines chinesen passen zudem hat sich ist die region mittlerweile für eine andere op entschieden ein
Absolutes thema wenn er als erstes neues dazu und zu allen anderen themen erfahren wollt dann meldet euch hierbei
Whatsapp andern erfahrt ihr vor allen anderen vom neuesten video
garantiert ihr könnt dort direkt in der redaktion von klicks um mitmachen und themen vorschlagen oder
Fragen zu videos stellen der direkte draht zu mir einfach eben hier draufklicken und natürlich nicht das abo mit
gloco zu weiter vergessen hier geht es weiter mit dafür draufklicken
mensch wird zur schimäre mit schweine organ ansonsten wenn ich mal sagen bis dann
bleibt dran